Going on, Kevin.
Hey, Brian, good to see you. Hey, Noah.
And you?
How's everyone doing?
Hey, sir, how are you doing?
Think very well. How are you?
Not too shabby for a Thursday.
Yeah.
I thought.
Since tomorrow is a holidays, it's a extended, you know, weekend. I thought you may be off by now, but it seems like everyone is working at CDG.
We're just waiting on you and then we're going to start partying.
Yeah.
Let's go then. I'm going to keep my... I'm going to disconnect this meeting. We are done. Let's go enjoy.
You betcha.
All right, bye.
Why, why not? Well, yeah, let's go, yeah.
Good talking to you. Everything's good. Mandy's good. Let's go.
Yeah.
The.
That's so sweet. All right, so is Kris joining it?
Now, do you know if Mike's Mike or Kris or anybody else joining us?
Ohh.
Here, I'll put it up there.
No response. I have no idea if they're enjoying or not. All you need is me. That's all you need.
You told me last time, I think it was you and Mike, that Kris.
I'm kidding.
I know.
He, he was being * ****.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm kidding. Look, it's a...
Yeah.
He was being very egotistical.
You only need me.
Yeah.
Brian, you can go ahead and live by.
Once upon a time I was that guy. Okay, bye.
I really don't have to be on this call. I just like to say hi.
But.
Okay.
I am not in charge of Mandy anymore.
Yeah.
I'm just here for client vendor relations.
Relationship building.
I'm just here to see.
Partner. Partner relations. I apologize. Partner relations. Yeah.
There you go, there you go.
I'm just here to see Kevin's beard get longer and longer every time.
Yeah.
Yeah, thanks, thanks. It's just that I'm not getting enough time to go to the barber, so I just keep on growing, and that's what it is now.
I, I...
I aspire to have a beard like his one day.
I hope so. All the best. It's going to take time. You just need to be patient, right? Brian tried it once. I still remember. But then I don't know what happened. He decided to trim it.
Yeah, I just need...
Yeah.
It started looking really not good. I didn't like it. So I like it better, more shorn up, but still long enough to, you know, run your fingers through.
You start looking homeless.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Right.
You gotta work on the gray.
This is how, this is how I try to run my finger.
What?
Ohh, stop it!
Look, look, he just uses just for men. That's why he doesn't have any gray.
Yeah.
Kip.
No, it's that glorious Indian purple or not perplexion.
Uhh...
Shoot, what's aura? Yeah, it just moves out of every everything is, yeah, it's not, I just found a word.
Arora, is that the right word?
Complexion, complexion, sorry, it's the complexion of his face.
He just created.
Complex, yeah, right, so this is the way it actually...
But I mean, Kevin does have Arora though. He does have Arora.
Oh, he has a great aura.
Thanks. Thank you, Noah. Thank you, Brian.
And then, and then there's Andy.
Yeah.
Hello, everyone.
Okay.
Andy is the Arora.
Arora, there you go, there you go. That was that was a good one. I like that, Arora.
Ha ha ha.
Hey, he walked right in. He brought it. Good, good for you. He brought it. We went from Arora to Arora.
Yeah.
Aurora, nice. You know, here's the fun part. If you spell Arora from the back side, it's the same thing.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
It's one of those perpet, what do they call those, palindromes or something like that?
Paladrone.
Isn't it interesting?
I was looking, I was like, what? I was like, *** ** * *****, he's right. It's the same thing.
You got a great name. You got a great surname, sir.
Yeah.
Thank you.
See.
All right, let's get this shindig on the road because I don't think Mike and Kris are going to show up and I've got beer to drink so.
Today you learned something new. Yeah, so...
There he goes. I'm going to just quickly wrap it up then. I won't take much time. Even though we will share this PPD with Kris and Mike if they have any questions. Oh, Kris is here. There you go.
Hey, Kris is here.
Kris is here.
On time, Kris.
Kris decided to finally show up.
Hello, hello.
As I do.
I think this is the first time Kris is joining our meetings, right? Brian, I haven't seen him.
Yes. First time caller, longtime listener.
Yes.
Welcome.
Welcome, welcome, Kris. Nice to meet you. I'm sure Brian and Noel must have told you about us. I don't want to get into the... That's fine. Great. I don't want to get into the interaction because Brian told me that he wants to, you know, go home after this, even though he's at home. He just want to, you know, wrap up everything and...
Yes, all good. All good things.
I am out.
It.
just have beer and just start his extended weekend. So we'll just try to wrap it up quickly. First of all, welcome everyone to our monthly business check-in. We'll be looking at May month's information because we rescheduled this meeting to this week. So this is why you're not looking at June, it's May.
Right, right.
Okay.
All right, getting into the agenda items, it stays pretty much the same. I'm going to quickly get into the highlights. It stays pretty much the same. Mandy is now certified AZ104. He is taking on the on-call responsibility. I haven't heard anything from Mandy which is causing any discomfort to him. So
All good from my side. I haven't heard anything from your end. So Noah, Brian, Kris, I believe everything is positive as per his on-call duties.
Yeah, Mandy is a, he's a rockstar.
Apart from this.
Perfect. Mike is also here. Hey, Mike, we were having a good time. You missed everything, Mike. We just had a fun. You missed everything. You just need to watch the recording now.
My apologies, guys.
Oh.
Oh, oh, no. Sorry, guys.
Look, Brian was at least courteous enough to say he needs his beer after the meeting. Mike is having his beer before the meeting.
Yeah.
Not during.
Look, you got to get all your fun in.
Yeah.
He's already dragged. That's right. Okay, so moving on. Yeah, so Noah, as you were saying that, you know, Mandy is doing great. So just keep me posted if there's anything else for the on-call duties. Okay. I just want to make sure that he's able to not only meet but exceed your expectations. Rest, he has been receiving great support from you guys. So thank you so much for supporting.
Mm.
Yeah.
Yeah, of course.
Andy, Chris is here. Chris, anything that you want to add before we move on to the next one?
No, I, you know, I'm really glad to have Mandy on the team, and he's a good worker, he.
You know, it doesn't cause any trouble for me.
Right.
I can only pray that everything stays the same and he doesn't give you any hard time. Otherwise, otherwise you always be after my life.
Yeah.
Singh.
Sometimes he is permitted to give me a hard time, so...
Because.
Huh.
Oh, once in a while, it's okay. Not every now and then. Okay, so as per his performance, well, I was very happy to see that in May, he exceeded his benchmark and his billable was at 81%.
So I don't know what happened, but he was super busy in May. His utilization was like at times even more than 100%.
But on average, if we look at from Feb to May, it's 68%. His ticket result rate is amazing, as always, 98% for May. As for the top service drivers, Office 365, 30%, end user 30%, Kobe user support 35, and then monitoring, SOC, knock alerts 5%.
So, that's the that's his report card for the month of May and starting till Feb.
to the way. Any questions, anyone?
No, Sir.
No, it was May when we onboarded Kellenberger. Is that why May was busier?
Order with 30.
I think that was their first full month of Kellenberger. Yeah.
Full month, yeah. Okay.
Okay, cool. Next up is CSAT is positive, so thank you so much, Noah, for filling it out. Appreciate it. Moving on to holiday.
Good.
Tomorrow is holiday. We all are enjoying ourselves. But after that, the next up is in September. It's a long way. We can discuss after that. close to. Yeah, that's true. That's so true. Yeah, but we'll discuss if you need Manu or not.
It'll be here before we know it.
Yeah.
That's something that we can discuss.
Okay, cool.
OK.
All right, Balit, I know Mike is coming, right? You got registered. That's what I, that's what Andy told me, right Andy?
Brandon Mac.
Mike Andy.
Mike and you. Perfect. So you're going to have a good time for sure.
Yeah, by Design will be part of Build It, so 5th August 5th it will be part of Build It event. You do have the agenda, right? But then with three days agenda.
Brian, do you have a video?
I don't have it in front of me, no, but I it's somewhere in my emails.
Cool. Maybe Andy can forward it to you. If you have any questions, you can just let us know. But thank you so much. Team GPS, we already know about it. I'm going to just quickly skip it. View forward remains the same. Mandy is working on his.
Yeah.
But.
on his skill set so that he can take up more advanced level of work. He is due for his level up in next couple of months, Brian. So once he's...
L1 Plus on our side will let you know, but he's still learning. We just want to give him some time to.
Make sure that he's ready. OK, and once he's through our assessment and the interview process, we'll let you know.
Rest, he has been doing great.
Yeah, just make sure Mike, Mike and Noah are a part of that conversation since since they're more involved, Mandy, than I am. But
Yeah.
Absolutely.
I'll be here rooting along.
Likewise, we all are. Okay, cool. Well, that's pretty much it, everyone. As I promised, I won't take much time. So I'm going to open up the forum now. So I'll go over to Mike first, because he joined a little late, so Mike.
Oh, wow. I don't have any additional comments. I think things are good.
Questions?
Awesome. Second person joining late was Kris. So Kris, over to you. I'm going to pick everyone now.
Yeah.
Ohh, so it's just alright, since this is my first time, can we go back to the other slide so I can understand, like...
Sure, which one?
what that means or what that goes or what that entails.
Which one do you want me to go to?
Next one, one before that one.
Like the...
This one? Pay forward.
This, yes, yes. So, what is this? I...
Yeah, so yeah, the idea of this slide is to see where things are moving forward, as in how we want Manu to perform and what exactly is he working on to provide you the value that you're looking for. It could be certifications, it could...
I'm just curious.
Could be up-skilling himself, it could be as a unit ITBD providing you with more additional resources, so anything and everything revolves around how we will, how we are looking ahead as for the coming months.
Could we work together on this perhaps? Because I meet with Mandy at least once a week and we do what we call a level up meeting. And it's more, it's not so much skill-based, it's more how to interact with customers, how to handle tickets. And I've just been kind of embellishing it more and more.
Sure.
Okay.
Mhm.
And I think this would actually align really well with what I'm doing with him.
OK.
Of course, Kris, what I can do is, since we have our Teams Federation open, I can message you on Monday or next week whenever you have time. We can correct, we can connect and then we can discuss. I'll share my points and then you can also share your feedback and together we'll see how we can.
Yeah.
I hope medical.
I would appreciate that.
Awesome, perfect. I know, I'm so sorry. I actually went pretty fast because Brian's beer is waiting, so I don't want to keep him waiting. You all know that.
Oh, it's fine if it gets warm.
Yeah, I was understanding the beer may be warm at this point.
Is used to drinking.
Josh, it's fine.
The.
It's fine.
But Kris, just to let you know that I will be sharing a copy with every one of you. So you can go through the presentation. If you have any questions, feel free to reach out. Okay.
But thank you so much for asking. I appreciate that. All right, perfect. So yeah, anything else, Kris, before I move to Noah?
I appreciate that.
No sir, but the more I do these, the more I'll have questions.
Awesome. Yeah, we have this monthly check-in. So every month when we connect, I'm sure you will have many things to share. So please do. Together if you have any questions, concerns, or feedback, we would love to hear from you.
Okay.
All right, Noah, over to you now. Questions, concerns, feedback.
I have nothing from my side.
Yeah, I think.
You kind of covered everything. I just need your beard routine so I can get mine looking a little better.
I wish I'm going to come to US and I'm going to give you some tips.
Okay, yeah. Like what kind of brush you use, shampoo, conditioner. I need all of it.
Exactly.
Oil, yeah, so I'll give you all the tips, right? OK.
The oils.
Okay.
Ha ha.
Thanks, thanks, Noah. I appreciate it, Brian.
Brian is already, you know, getting set up so that he can have his cold beer.
I'm pre-hydrating. That's all. I'm just pre-hydrating. That's just water. It's Pre. I'm just hydrating.
Yeah.
We all know that beer's in the cup.
Yeah, we all know it's water. Yeah, you're right, it's water.
Like, we can see it.
Look, I'm just saying, beer does have quite a bit of water in it, so it can also count as hydration.
Yeah.
Exactly.
And the cans don't fit inside of the cup. I can tell you that from firsthand experience.
There you go.
Everyone is questioning Brian now.
But.
Bye. Have a good weekend. I'm done.
Brian, hey, Brian, can you can you can you unblur your screen real quick and just show us inside the container? I think we need to see.
Yeah, it seems pretty interesting though.
Like, I heard the carbonation, but water does not have carbonation.
Maybe he's he's having a he's having soda.
Well, that's not any better.
Hmm.
Nope, because that looks like vodka.
That, that looks, that looks, that looks like vodka or tequila.
Wait, I got...
It's like...
But.
I gotta turn off the uh filter.
Who?
I turn off the filter.
Brian, I think we got the answer. This is exactly how vodka looks like.
This is the way what we what we were looking.
Look. Clear.
Look, what we were looking at, all the fogginess and the blurriness, that is what Brian's currently seeing after taking a sip of that.
Yeah.
Right.
But...
Okay, I love you, bye.
Right.
Alright guys, take care. Have a good one. Have a fantastic extended weekend. We'll see you next month. Take care guys. Bye bye.
Bye, have a good one.
Bye.
Every weekend.
Alright, bye.
Bye, Kevin. Thank you.
Right. Take care. You're welcome. Bye.
Andy, see ya.
He's already gone. He's like...
He, he, he, he's faster to the beer than I am.
There you go. All right then, enjoy yourself, Brian. Have a good one. Take care. You too. Bye.
Alright, brother, have a good weekend.
Blake.